my name is Julius matcha from trade and
investment Limpopo I'm the acting chief
executive officer there now South Africa
as a whole is going to host a the 2010
World Cup and this is a unique
opportunity for the whole of Africa
because in the history of this World Cup
it has never been hosted by any country
in Africa so that is why I've been
during the campaign they mentioned that
this is an African Cup and in the spirit
of regional economic integration we feel
that the World Cup is going to benefit
the whole of the continent in terms of
tourism and infrastructure development
and creating all of those linkages in
terms of regional economic integration
in the spirit of napot